[Musique]
et
bonjour la réunion bonjour le monde
comment ils et comment il l'oeil comment
ça va alors aujourd'hui une fois n'est
pas coutume on va pas faire de caries
mais plus à part marmaille affole pas
bateau on va tous découvrir sur
l'alambic les essences les huiles
essentielles de deux de géraniums oui
oui
donc on est sur la route du maïdo et on
va se retrouver à la maison du géranium
poursuivaient à gaza
[Musique]
lui
alors on va retrouver jean jacques le
oui bonjour comment il échangea quand ça
va bien bien mon bain bienvenus ça va
bien ça va c'est toi le spécialiste
géraniums avec mcdo lentz a fait 3e
génération a fait des yeux l'essentiel
eh ben dis donc comme on est bien alors
expliquez nous un petit peu vite fait où
ça nous les voilà déjà fait là on est
sur la route du maïdo et on est située à
1400 mètres d'altitude quand même voilà
ça fait ici ça fait battus à 2400 m
d'altitude ça fait nous l'a créé une
petite activité
tafani fait des huiles essentielles et
puis juste en face de nous nous ne nous
y sommes pour une boîte tous les ans
juste à côté
[Musique]
mais moi aussi a du mal à diversifier ne
fait à peu près une dizaine d'huiles
essentielles géraniums il fait
cryptomérias il fait du contenu musical
et jennifer romarin il fait si près
enfin il fait toutes les plantes et de
rock n' y trouve comme la médecine en
aromathérapie aujourd'hui développe
beaucoup de gens il soigne aux états
unis essentielle c'est clair et là je
dans notre jardin ici par une enquête du
genre jean une énième petit champ
géraniums et puis j des hyènes et
petitjean géraniums de la pro cee'd et
des plantes médicinales et nous n'allons
plante aussi quelques plantes et enduite
d'un montage de son histoire normalement
notre télé là normalement et doit sortir
le 2
on
du roi
tu as donné ta de plantes je mens tu
peux que l'on peut trouver d'autres
j'adore ça fait benoït siméon géraniums
ça fait aussi c'est un jardin ni des
coûts géraniums mais ne découvre aussi
un petit peu de côté jardin créole
je connais jean d'école entre nous vient
de passer là toute allure on est à peu
près trois variétés de fuchsia juste à
côté
la plante aussi des romarins comme il
faisait l'essentiel remarquer pour monde
de monotypes et au romarin est synonyme
des pizzas capote bagarre contre les 400
toulis dans ce petit coin là nous menace
cinq variétés de géranium odorant darcos
variété d'uranium après géranium odorant
ya des centaines de variétés d'accord
mais parmi ces centaines de variétés la
ya qu une seule variété qu'on plante
pour son huile essentielle
il ya mon taoussa un instant juste à
côté
et géraniums c'est celui-là la réalité
ça c'est les géraniums il fait
l'essentiel avec d'uranium
rosa et nous à la réunion les ted rogers
1810 1810 il ne commence plantes aller à
partir des années 1860 12 sur la plaine
des palmistes mais plaine des palmistes
le climat n'était pas bon du tout il
était pas bon parce qu'ils étaient trop
subi
lytro de brouillard safetic sonné j'ai
rallumé faut donner un peu de l'eau mais
faut pas de notre dos parce que s'il y
en a trop de l'eau sa fille pourrie le
pied et pinel maladie intervient
géraniums qu'il n'y a pas là et la
rouille
il savait comme le climat n'était pas
bon la plaine des palmistes nouna
commencent à planter dans les audois 6,6
à partir des années 1920
voilà longtemps les plus efficaces et
pas assez fait baisser comme des nantis
témoigne lui aussi est on dans les
années 1920 jusqu'à les années 1980 à la
réunion ici nous l'avait quinze mille
hectares plantés en géraniums 15000 etc
tenté commence depuis dans les hauts de
sainte marie jusqu'à dans les hauts de
saint joseph
tu as tout via sont là ils étaient
couverts d'uranium et aujourd'hui je
vais bien 2014 nous l'été à 150 hectares
et aujourd'hui nous les entre 70 et 80
ha ça fait en deux ans nous la paix de
50 poissons de surface on géraniums mais
économiquement parlant
koné ranimer difficile vu du géranium en
voilà difficile vu que géraniums parce
que nous même jadis nous tiens maison
géraniums sachions voilà ça fait nizet
garder la culture et puis nous l'avons
de notre activité au public
ça fait comme il fait de viser un petit
peu visites guidées tout cela il
permettra de tenir et puis comme il fait
plusieurs nous fait cryptomérias kruth
manifestent depuis 26 ans et comme il
fait qu'ali psychique ans tout cela la
saf et complète un petit peu mais
géraniums tout seul aujourd'hui
impossible de vivre uniquement de cette
activité où le montant -
c'est pas parce que tu as une petite
branche même comme la manière de
compagnie
[Musique]
c'est un travail tout se fait à la main
voirie ou des friches à la main que sa
tronçonneuse tout cela ou thaï beach
avec un couteau ou fouiller trouve avec
la pioche ou mais de la boutique dans
mêmes pour désherber à la pioche et
gratte et même pour distiller aussi en
général tient à la main au sécateur les
hormones de curage du dos
[Musique]
tous ces risques à manet
lavallée
de vous lire
[Musique]
il a nous les à-côtés l'alambic je vais
bien depuis son introduction à la
réunion géraniums ça toujours rester des
alambics traditionnels comme ça des
alambics en cuivre
mais aujourd'hui fait plus dynamiques en
cuivre il fait des anglicans inox
mais nous on préfère le cuivre parce que
lui l'essentiel est plus jolie dans
lequel il est même niveau le pas en fin
aussi les plus agréables ou pas la main
qu'on dit plus joli c'est au niveau de
la couleur la couleur la couleur mais
même niveau le parfum même l'essentiel
les plus agréables et là c'est à dire
bon comme la mère de fitch ou de
logiquement ses ebooks bien mais nous va
commencer à jal était tout de suite et
en général je vais bien nous mettre 250
litres d'eau dans la lah en a cure voilà
ce croisions en voilà nous placera dans
le fond l'occasion il fait peu près 50
cm de hauteur position est bien assise
et un ami ben dans l'eau c'est une
de géraniums honoré mais n'auraient plus
à bouillon de brède une supposée ryan
nos rendements ils varient en fonction
landreau plan d'année et si à cette
altitude là pour les 300 kg n'y gagnent
à peu près entre eux entre 30 à 40
centimes il essentiellement pour les 300
350 kg
[Musique]
là où raging je suis même oublié pour
enfoncer un peu avant d'être aussi bien
sur la meme pas beaucoup de travail mais
on dirait madame à mettre le mauvais
choix sur mes souliers
toi tu vas avoir des problèmes
si si si si vous tassez travail
difficile mais c'est un travail
primordial pour la pour la connaissance
de notre culture et de et du
savoir-faire nos anciens aussi beaucoup
[Musique]
rien ne se jette on prend le fumier du
géranium et on va colmater tout toi pour
empêcher en fait là va peut être sortir
en gros c'est un peu sahraoui
[Musique]
en venir à youtube qu'il n'ya pas
l'école jean yanne de serpentins et le
serpentin sa ressource en eau j ai lu 6
à pantin fait entre 12 et 17 mètres de
long la vapeur d'eau est passée entre la
masse végétale est en train de lui
l'essentiel arrivé ici ça fait là sauf
la condensation saf la vapeur d'eau
devient l'hydrolat que nous appelle
thilo il avait perdu elle devient lui le
vert voilà ça fait de l'équipe d'harry
par là et les sorciers c'est à dire ça
c'est une bouteille qu'on a cassé le
fond le tuyau là il est légèrement
recourbé intérêts du vase ça va être du
liquide harry dans le vase
lulu com est plus léger et modulable
dans la bouteille et le trop plein d'eau
il revient de ce côté par là une fois
que ça commence à couler 6 en deux
heures et demie on arrivait street en
huiles essentielles
[Musique]
géraniums emballé finette style et un la
noire monte en l'air dans la salle me
wanna table donc je pense que ne doit
pas aussi n'oublions pas le doute à leur
diamant un petit peu les produits kounen
à cette table main les justes le jury
donne envie de goûter déjà premièrement
mais vous mais ça fait bien et nous ici
maison géraniums ça fait bon on y fait
la distillation et après bon une fois
fini le fait la distillation il fait des
visites guidées nouna une boutique
d'artisanat qui est différent nos
produits et apprennent à la salle ici la
salle ici nous fait de repas sur
réservation à partir de 20 personnes
hélas dans la visite guidée les compris
aussi une petite dégustation des petites
dégustations des produits qu'il fabrique
ici sur place
là par exemple ni fabriqué ni fait du
sirop pour n'y fait du sirop programme
arranger je redis radium siro vanille
gingembre ni fait de la confiture
confiture banane goyavier n'y fait la
gelée de géraniums je dirais même en
général ni manger du foie gras par
exemple fin d'année après une énergie
une petite dégustation niveau quelques
petits rhum arrangé qui n'y fait il
remarquer géraniums je suis là à jeun
jambes le goût d'un tube hot swap je
suis comment façonner monza ces petits
clients
je veux le paradigme je vois le paradis
je vois je vois les anges aux mondiaux
mais c'est bon c'est bon là je les les
confitures tout ça va c'est isabelle qui
prépare qui fait la gelée et st-gelais
des géraniums qui a été fait hier après
midi
d'accord on par la main de isabelle oui
ben tiens mon équipe où s'équilibrent et
isabelle dumont madame madame nous a
fait nous travaillons ensemble depuis
18 depuis 18 ans le 1er mai
[Musique]
maintenant ma bouche testing est bien
doux avec des petits produits locaux
fait maison
par contre un petit peu comment ou avec
coo de madame la rivale à vous avez déjà
mans et même famille plants de géraniums
ça fait nous mêmes la moyenne à majella
titre prend ce même l'origine et à la
petite france vécu juste en dessous et
ça fait nous mêmes la na toujours plan
dire à niort et auparavant nous mêmes
côté notre allant de géraniums n'avait
touristes est bien d'accord ça fait mal
est fait la formation guide pays et
après au bout de quelques années à l'ajv
un étang et bien moi pas tu fais mon
service militaire et comment la
retourner musiciens de 1000 tonnes
d'uranium mais la lépi personne peut
occuper et motiver un coin cette
activité là sur la route maïdo mais là
la propose à nous ici là les situe à
1400 et celle là nous la décide de faire
là à cet endroit là au jeu a dit m on y
fait des visites guidées n'y fait aussi
nous dans la boutique juste à côté
niveau on ne produit ni fait aussi des
repas voilà justement mais voleur mais
voulait revenir là dessus parce que
justement votre mana une salle avec pas
mal de table et 2 et 2 et de chaises
couvert on va dire donc diamant un petit
peu comment ça se passe pour l'instant
ni fonctionne depuis deux ans que ni
fait des repas sur réservation pour les
groupes
et bientôt nous sera ouvert aux
individuels aussi c'est que ce soit il
veut manger bien sur réservation ni
tenir au téléphone 82 15 00 tout est dit
la vie est belle hein toi tu as mal tu
as mal au coude
t'inquiète temps à clefs la tente on va
te faisais ce qu'il faut dont on va
donner c'est faux parfait ben merci bien
mais à certains projets ne retrouve
maman l'a appris beaucoup de choses et
mes voeux mais si au bout
ben merci alors il faudra oui oui il va
revenir mais si notre film lesbien ya
trop wallon
l'émission se termine on s'est arrêté à
petit france le dernier village avant
d'arriver au maïdo alors moi j'avais mal
au dos c'est fini j'avais la grippe
c'est fini parce qu'on revient juste de
la maison du géranium
oui messieurs dames alors moi je vous
conseille d'y aller l'accueil est juste
parfait je vous dis tout simplement à la
prochaine et comme dit la romance on
n'est pas sorti de l'auberge mais alors
pas du tout
[Musique]
une